[Music]
hello everyone and welcome to my talk
today emotional intelligence we're going
to tell you all about how to build
smarter animations my name is Nick
butcher
yes this would quick onward hello here
we go well my name is Nick butcher I am
an engineer on the Android developer
relations team and I focus mostly on UI
design and development so I spent a lot
of time on the main thread and I'm gonna
go through a lot of code today this is
i/o that's what you want right and so
but don't worry about taking photos of
the slides or worrying about referring
back later that and all of this talk is
gonna be uploaded later to this URL or
if you're watching on the recording you
can find it right now hopefully and so
yeah so you can follow along and they'll
be gist of code and everything so today
I want to talk to you about animations I
think animations are super important
hashtag animations matter and often I
think animations are thought of as
delight or polish or something sprinkled
on at the end of a development process
and I think that's a massive shame and I
think that contributes the reason why
they're often the first things on the
chopping block when time is tight and
features a crunching animations I think
are really important for and usability
of your application they can explain a
state change so that the user knows
what's going on they can establish a
spatial model so that you have a sense
of place within the application
or they can hint at how you can interact
with them so they're very important in
my opinion but I think animations are
currently under threat and that's due to
changes in the way that we are
architecting our applications so there's
a movement towards and having the
controller of your application be
outside of the view layer right and it's
something like a view model then
publishes and a state of the application
so a UI model view state whatever you
might call it is essentially and the
entire state of your application and
needed to render on the screen and as
things change in your back-end say a
network request comes in or the user
performs an action and interaction this
updates the state in your view model and
they publish a new version of this UI
state there's lots of benefits
this kind of architecture such as being
able to reason about the entire state
for application at once and or easier
testing and so on and so forth but I'm
not going to go into those today I'd
encourage you to check out
unidirectional data flow or patterns
such as MPI
or even libraries such as Mavericks or
Mobius for helping to implement this
what I do want to talk about is the
observers of this stream of data at the
other end so when you get these stream
of UI models you then need to bind it to
your into your views to set these values
to set up the state of your views now
having the stream of mui models is kind
of like a pure function you want to have
this like pure input and perform an
action it essentially wants to be very
stateless on the other side animations
essentially very stateful they want to
know about set they're all about setting
a value from one value to another value
over a period of time so this I think is
the ultimate tension right now but this
moves this new architecture it's
becoming harder to kind of join these
two stateless and stateful and worlds so
today I want to focus in on some tools
and some techniques that you can use in
your applications right now in order to
enable you to do animations because I
think it's a shame I think a lot of
people are finding it hard to kind of
square this circle to kind of marry
these two and models and as such I think
animations are under threat so to look
at these metals and techniques let's
start off with a simple minimum viable
screen where we have some kind of logon
form and when you hit logon and
crucially I don't want I want to hide
the login button and show you some kind
of progress spinner but I don't want it
just to blink out of visibility and
change I want it to animate out and the
spinner to animate in so the UI model
the state for this screen might look
something like this a simple data class
with a couple of billions about what's
going on and you can then bind this into
your your view layer to your application
using some kind of library functions
like this where set visibility in this
static well before we animate it does
something very simple like setting the
views visibility and based on that
boolean state so how can we animate
something like this
so a and
you're kind of naive way to do this
might be something like this where we're
just running a animation - in this
example fade in of you or when we're
fading it out we have to of course set
the visibility to gone because otherwise
the button stays present in the
hierarchy receiving touches and so forth
so we all notice we're all Android yes
we have to use the Alpha property and
then set the visibility as well but
doing something like this and might
yield to interesting results like for
example just doing that is actually
running you can see every time I do a
keystroke here hopefully you see the
spinner kind of like shows up briefly
and then fades out which is not what I
wanted or if I managed to actually
finish the form and hit the login button
and we see some weirdness going on where
they're kind of overlapping and then all
of a sudden both views are gone and like
what's going on there essentially what
is going on is with this model where
lots of them updates are being published
at once you can get into some corner
cases which you have to consider ahead
of time and I actually would like to
propose free kind of principles or
tenants which one would make a good
animation in this world which are that
they should be reentrant continuous and
smooth let's look at each of these so
the first step reentrant is a fancy
computer science word for essentially
the your your function should be able to
be interrupted and called again at any
time so essentially we're saying it will
through in this state where a new model
can be published at any time and you're
observing it if you're running
animations which also take a period of
time you need to be prepared for a model
being published and while the animation
is still running you need to be able to
respond to them safely and the second
one is continuous and if you look at
this example of an animation here where
this view is scaling changing scale and
color as I touch it I think looks fine
if I kind of touch it and it scales to
completion I let go and it scales back
to normal state but if I touch kind of
rapidly you can see is jumping in scale
and color and this kind of discontent
continuity is very jarring it can be
very kind of like abrupt this change to
your users which isn't lead to a very
and pleasant user experience essentially
animations are all about smoothly
changing a value over time like that's
kind of what an animation is if we're
not going to prepared for this new value
coming in at a certain time you can have
something like this
where we're midway through one curve and
then suddenly we jump and we have this
discontinuity which is which lead to the
most poor user experience and the last
tenant I wanna propose is one of
smoothness and by which I mean take this
example where I'm animating a view to
either the top left or top right then
depending on pushing this button if and
now I hit the top right button twice you
can see it slows down and then animates
again because a new event came in it
kicked off a new animation and but
because the animate each animation had
the same duration it leads to this kind
of like discontinuity in the velocity so
it slows down and this kind of looks
kind of terrible similarly if I can
retarget it so it's going one way and
then I send it off to the left I left it
in to the right you can see it just kind
of stops suddenly and then reverses
direction now nothing in the real world
and kind of like has this instantaneous
change interaction or velocity and so
this feels very unnatural to us so let's
look at solving these problems in our
code so first up let's take a look at
that continuous property that it jumped
midway through and you can see here and
that I've kind of made some assumptions
read that when you want to show
something that you I'm going to animate
this visibility it's alpha property so
from 0 to 1 or 1 to 0 so this is kind of
like making the assumption of the
current value what we can and do with
animators instead is just remove that
initial value so just say animate to
this value and the way the object
animator and property system works is
the property here alpha both tells you
how to set the kind of animated value on
the view as well but also offers how to
get it so if you omit the from value it
will read the views current alpha and
it'll start from there which is what we
want we don't want the value to jump
around so that was easily solved and but
let's take a look at the reentrant
problem that's slightly before Nia and
so the reentrant property essentially is
that we want to be able to call this at
any time and not have any kind of side
effects lingering around so essentially
what we need to do is clean up after
ourselves we need to kind of cancel any
running animation that's going on but if
you look at this code here and we're not
actually holding a reference to the
animations right we just create them and
the cool star and then forget about them
there's no reference held onto it
so what we can do is fix that actually
first before that would then let's not
run an animation if we don't need to so
in that instance where I was typing
typing typing and it was like all the
time saying I want the again spinner to
be invisible
it was always running that animation but
we want to actually skip that animation
if you don't need to so here what we're
simply doing was saying if we're
targeting like you know if we're going
to go fade it out to zero if it's
already faded out just return early so
bail early so short-circuit the method
and but yeah if we wanted to cancel our
running animation and there's kind of
like mid progress then we need to kind
of store it somewhere so that we can
have access to the animator to cancel it
such that we can when a new invocation
comes around we can cancel any running
animations and before setting up the new
animation so we could do this we could
store it somewhere but where would you
store it these functions are essentially
kind of pure functions that's kind of an
static so the only option really is to
store it really in the view itself but
view already offers such a method for
this it actually has something called a
view property animator which is what's
returned we call viewed or animates
which allows you to do this kind of get
access retrieve any running cut and
animations so if we swap out our code
from using object animator to using view
view property animator instead then we
get some of these properties so what
happens here is when you call view dot
animate if there's already an animation
running over that same property it will
be canceled for us and then the new
animation will be run so that's exactly
what we want even more and view property
animator offers this with end action API
which takes a runnable so the cool thing
about this is this this action will only
be invoked if the animation runs to
completion it won't be invoked if the
animation is canceled so if a new value
comes in then the old animation is
canceled and the action is only runs if
it completes which is exactly the kind
of properties that we want there's still
a few problems with this system here
though so what happens if we're midway
through an animation well we just said
that it's going to cancel the previous
animation and run it and you
so that's going to violate our smooth
property because if we're already
animating to the right target value in a
new value comes in it will still kind of
cancel it and start again so you'll get
this kind of like stutter change in it
we could for example store the current
value that and the animator is running
is kind of currently animating too and
if a new update to the same value comes
in we could perhaps skip that update but
that's not going to help us out in the
case where we're trying to retarget to a
new value that comes in we way through
an animation so how we're going to solve
this problem of smoothness and whether
there's actually a library out there
which I think a lot of developers
haven't really paid much attention to
which is the physics based property and
animation system and I think maybe
people who have skipped it because we
look at and some of the samples or demos
or even our developer documentation here
and they see things like these bouncy
animations and think hey that's you know
fine if I want to make a bouncy effect
but it's not for me for general UI kind
of animation that's a shame
because you can actually very easily
turn off the bounciness and what's left
is a very powerful physics based system
which has a number of properties which
are useful for these kind of cases that
we're trying to solve so for example if
you return to our square going to the
left or right and we run it with a
physics-based and a spring system
underneath it because it has a physics
system underneath it when you retarget
it to a new value it maintains things
like the velocity for you and it gives
us these properties we're looking for
where and if you try and go to the same
place twice
it maintains the velocity even though
it's starting a new animation or if you
retarget to an another destination it
slows down and changes direction very
very smoothly by maintaining the
velocity for you so if you haven't
looked at Springs the API looks very
similar to the animated system where you
have a subject being animated a property
which you want to animate here the
translation X a target value and then
you call start on it but for me the real
power comes when you instead of using
start you use this animate to final
position API and what this does is if
the animation isn't started it will just
kick it off but crucially if an
animation is running and
then it will retarget it and this will
do that magic of maintaining the
velocity for us and updating the target
buddy
so the key thing there was if the
animation was already running so we want
something like the view property
animator we saw before which held onto a
reference to any running animation such
that we can access it and cancel it or
update it and unfortunately view doesn't
have you know get spring method or you
know like like animate has so that it
can return you a handy one of these so
let's build one and so this is an
extension property I've been playing
with and the solution function excuse me
adding an on view whereby you pass it a
property a view pops you onto animates
this is things like translation X or
alpha or so on and it will return you a
spring animation and what I do is I
stash the running spring as a tag on the
view so it can hold on to it so going
through it here what I do is I map the
property to a key such that you can
store it in the tag and then try and
retrieve it from the views tag system so
if there's one already running will get
access to that or if it's not if there
isn't one already set up already stored
then we'll create a new spring animation
and store it in the views tag and then
return it so a handy little and you know
small extension function like this it
helps you get access to a spring for a
given view and what that means is that
we can at the call site to have a nice
clean something like this well you just
do view dot spring for the translation X
and the crucially this will either
return you a new spring animation or one
that's already running which is exactly
what we want and then we can use that
animate to final position syntax and to
update a running animation so what might
this look like in our binding function
that we're talking about so here we were
we were using the view property animator
we can sub this out use the extension
function and grab access to the or
create a new spring and animate it to
the final value that we want the
eagle-eyed amongst you might have
noticed I kind of we would regress some
functionality there we lost the end
listener you can of course still do this
and you know this spring animation that
system has listeners as well so here we
can add this endless notice
visibility - gone a bit at the end and
but there's a slight caveat in that in
order to remove a listener which we
would have to do first ahead of time you
need a hard reference to it you can't
just call clear or any search method
like this so we need to store the
listener and again I'm using the view
tag here as a handy way to stash it
interview such that before and setting
up a new animation we can cancel any
previous end listeners so it's a bit of
a faff you have to be a bit careful the
way you write these animations that you
have to be careful that they are
reentrant especially but the nice thing
is that you kind of write these
functions there's only like a handful
these functions you need to do you need
to write one for like alpha one for
translation 1/4 scale whatever it might
be and you stash them in a library and
and then you can use them throughout
your code base use them in a number of
places you just write them a couple of
times and correctly and then use them
for route and now looking at Springs are
kind of simplified the creation a little
bit so just like when you create an
object animator or view property
animator you've probably customized
things like the interpolation or the
duration and Springs don't really have
those concepts because their physics
base they have kind of things that
describe the physics system underneath
it so as sites you probably wanted to do
like customize the spring forces to set
the damping ratio and the stiffness so
the damping ratio controls that
bounciness we just talked about and the
stiffness and controls like how fast the
spring moves to equilibrium state so if
you don't set these you'll get these
default values and it's kind of like
medium bouncy or medium stiffness which
is kind of what we saw in an example
before and but I found there's some kind
of default values that could generally
applicable for UI work so and I added
these to the extension function to make
it and very easy to get this kind of
some default and behavior that works
well for most cases so turning off the
bouncing that's got all together and
setting a slightly higher stiffness
ratio but because their default
parameters it makes it super easy that
you can just pass an alternate value at
the call site if you want to customize
an animation to make it slightly snap
here for example so to give you a kind
of a real example of this and they're
going to take a look at a recycler view
item animator so recyclerview does a lot
of stuff for you right so using digital
and fine
grayned a tap to updates it will give
you free animations essentially so in
this example I've got a grid and then
when I hit the shuffle button it's
moving some items around so this is with
the default item animator and you can
see it's got that kind of you know just
continuous or not very smooth and it's
continuous but not very smooth
animations when items come in we can sub
this out for this kind of spring based
system and we can see that when item the
new updates come in you can see that
they smoothly animates the final place
and this might seem like a kind of toy
example for slides but this is probably
quite close to what's actually happening
in your apps how many apps grab stuff on
the internet and shove it into a
recycler view and you know this is
obviously like an asynchronous operation
so updates can come in at any time or
maybe you scroll and you um information
is coming in but I kind of like thinking
about and making the animations that
happen when this asynchronous data here
kind of comes back and as smooth as
possible you can really kind of like
improve the user experience in your app
and so this is a kind of slight
simplification of the code because I'm
extending default item animator is a
little bit involved and but essentially
it comes down to setting up some
translations on some views and then when
you want to animate it you just animate
those translations back down to zero so
we just use the exact same extension
function we looked at before to create
or grab an already running spring
animation over the translation
properties and animate them down to zero
and this is essentially what it gets to
give you that kind of nice smooth
behavior and I'll put this in there just
in case anyone wants to take a look so
we just kind of general approach to how
to animate view properties but view
properties aren't the only things that
you want to animate and have a respond
to kind of like new states of your
application it's going to take a look at
a few classes that you should be aware
of that can help you to do this in other
party of application so draw balls for
example often you want to set their
state and but you don't always want that
to be just kind of like a static state
you sometimes want to animate those
strength changes I think everyone is
familiar hopefully with this stateless
drawable class so you can you know to
fine in a Czech state I want this raw
ball in an unchecked state I want that
drawable but I don't think as many
people are super familiar with the
animated version of this so this is
introduced in lollipop API 21 there's
also part of jetpack taken
use it back to 16 so this lets you in
addition to those states it lets you
name those states in order that you can
provide a transition when moving between
any of those states and these
transitions the draw ball here can be in
the form of either an animated vector
drawable or an animation drawable kind
of like a frame sequence and so then the
calling code becomes super simple so in
your binding you just have to you know
set say the check state to something in
your UI model and the class itself under
the hood will take care of running the
transitions that you define for it so
this looks like something like this so
this is from the Android developer
summit application where you know you're
tapping the star and rather than it just
changing you can get this kind of like
scale animation it can be used like
pretty much everywhere you can use drawl
so in the bottom navigation view for
example when you select a section they
get to the checked or selected state
after which get set and we can set a
transition for running between those
states you get these nice little
animations as you enter the state and
all of this is define is completely
declarative so all I have to do is set
the icon to an animated stateless robot
like this and I'll get this behavior I
don't have to maintain a stable you
worry about what state it was in it will
get canceled for me or the new one will
get set for me automatically and we can
actually extend this and behavior to
reduce some quite powerful effects and
so this is the the book you know reserve
a spot button from the google i/o
application which I guess everyone in
this room is probably used and so like
reserving a spot in a session is quite a
critical kind of action right we don't
want to just update the UI
optimistically and say you got a ticket
well you might not have we won't
actually do a network request and
confirm that you've got a seat before we
tell people that or that you know you
know if you've been wait-listed or so on
so you know there's quite a lot of
information being communicated in this
button but this is actually powered but
entirely by a single animated stateless
trouble and so you can see here that we
have some states in there that have the
different drawable states and but you
might be looking at and thinking what
state reserved or state wait-listed I've
never seen those on Android classes
before that's because I'm not sure how
many people are familiar that the fact
that you can actually add your
in states and to views which can be
super powerful if you want to then use
it in conjunction with this technique
like an animated stateless Roble so this
can then power running the right
transition whenever you set one of your
custom states onto a view and the way
you do this is it looks quite similar to
defining custom attributes for a custom
view you can define it in a terse file
the states you want to support and then
we actually wrapped up this behavior
into an enum because there were a few
things we wanted to change when their
button changes States so not just the
state this kind of this attribute state
but also we wanted to change the content
description or some text that gets
displayed with the buttons we wrap this
all up into a innumerous States and
setting this draw the attribute a state
as well as these other things then we
extend the app compat button image
button class in this case and a couple
things
first we have to expose a property which
is one of these enum values and
crucially in that whenever that changes
we call refresh drawable state this is
your hook into the view system to say
hey my state has changed and that in
turn will kick off the later updates to
actually run the transitions the other
thing you have to do is you have to
override on create drawable state which
is essentially how you're telling the
system what state you're and currently
in so here you have to call this merge
drawable States method and pass in your
current state this is the kind of
attribute resource which if I expand it
out from the enum value is this int
array of the state that you're currently
in so by doing this we can get some
pretty and powerful behavior so we can
have these like transitions between all
these and given States but as you saw
you know this can get quite and you know
quite a lot because there's six
different states if you want to be able
to animate between each and every one of
those states you basically end it with
an n-by-n problem so you'd have to kind
of define 36 different transitions there
which sounds and pretty hard so what we
did instead is we had a policy of always
going through an intermediary state this
pending state we see the hourglass going
round and round
so as search if you wanted to go from
reservable to reserved and you always go
for this intermediary state and that
import made us
that cut down the number of transitions
that we had to run from n-by-n to just
to n so we only had to write 12 animated
vectors luckily I like writing animated
vectors and if you're running a lucky
enough to be running on API 23 or beyond
as your main SDK then you can use the
platform's animated vector drawable
class instead of the support libraries
one which also supports reversing and so
you can only write n just six different
Ran's issues and have them reverse when
going in the opposite direction but I
guess most people aren't in that well
just yet one note about doing this kind
of thing is that we wanted to have this
nice intermediate state where it's like
animating there our class and one
current limitation of the animated
vector drawable class is that you can't
a repeat count on animator set you can
only set it on leaf animator object
object animators so here we're I'm
saying them the repeat counter minus 1
which is infinite so just infinitely
animate you have to be able to structure
animations in such a way to achieve this
so how does the animate stateless Rob
will help us against these kind of goals
which I set out for my animations they
only you really tick one box for me here
they're re-entrant so it maintains the
state for me so if I enter into a new
state it will cancel everything and it
will start the new transition for me
automatically
it's neither continuous or smooth so it
won't kind of like you for halfway
through an animation do some kind of
magic to move from that halfway state to
the end state you've defined and but I
think this is pretty useful for a class
which is out the box you don't have to
write any code essentially you just have
to provide different transitions relate
between the states and so it's a really
handy class to have in your tool belt if
you need to animate and the transition
of drawables closely related or similar
concept really to animate state of this
robot is this state list animator which
is actually do similar things for views
so for example in this application I
have some kind of frederick conversation
and when you select a single comment i
wanted to have this kind of transition
where i animate the elevation and the
background color of the selected content
and this is entirely declaratively
powered by the stateless animator class
and so stateless animator is essentially
selector where within each item tag
within each item which is a given state
you can define these child animations to
be run I don't know why it's not an
animated selector but it's a selector
anyway and so here you can see I am
running an animation over the background
color and the translation Z property
whenever it go into a certain state and
here I would just want to point out you
don't have to create your own view
States if you don't need them so here we
just reused the Android activated state
which is you know available on every
view so while defining custom view
states is super powerful if you have
multiple states you want to move into
and he wants it to be more meaningful
and semantic and you can just reuse some
of the Android States and so stateless
animator how does this kind of like
score on our chart so just like an
animated say so although it's re-entrant
so it will maintain the state so if your
new state comes in it will cancel
anything that was previously running and
move you into the new state it's kind of
semi continuous I'll give it like half a
mark here and it really comes down to
the fact that it's just running these
object animators and just like we looked
at before and you can provide a from
value in a to value so just by admitting
the from value and it will try and query
the current value in order to run it but
I said try because this is essentially a
kind of reflection based approach so
view has a get translation Z method on
it so it can query the translation Z and
it will then so translation Z will be
continuous but there is no get
background color method on view
essentially there's a set background
color method which is a convenience
method almost it takes that color and
coerces it into a color drawable and
sets the color drawer on the view but
there's no getter for it so you have to
be a bit careful about if you want to
make this continuous about using
properties which are animatable that you
can read their current value in order to
get this continuous property and the
last one we talk about is an approach to
doing custom view animation so let's
walk through an example of what I mean
by that so in the Google i/o application
again and we have these filter screen
where you can customize the schedule to
see the topics that are we interested in
you're just interested in Android and
sessions right and so this is a custom
view
because we want to have complete control
over the rendering of it and there's a
few games going on with this animation
so when you select it there's the kind
of the colored circle both increases in
size as well as we animate its center to
be in the center of the chip we animate
the text position and then we also scale
up the draw ball which is that clear X
other side so you could think of a way
of writing this as a custom animation
whereby you create animators for each of
those things which is changing when you
run those animations individually so an
animation for the circle radius one for
the circle center and then you could
perhaps put them into an animator set
and try and control them and orchestrate
them my lap but instead the way we went
for this is we instead have a single and
progress property which is just a float
which runs from 0 to 1 and we just run a
single animation over that progress
property and then what we do is we drive
the rendering to query that progress
property so for the circle radius for
example we say what radius should I be
were from between this start value and
that end value for a given progress and
if you haven't seen the loop function
before is a very common animation kind
of utility which means linearly
interpolate which will do just that
so between this value and this value for
a given progress what should I be and
the key takeaway here is that if you
have this single progress function and
then you can just animate it very easily
so you can hook this up to a spring like
we looked at before and have this
entirely be continuous and smooth by
running spring animations and be able to
retarget it to something else rather
than having to try and orchestrate
multiple and animate assets which can be
a pain or you could hook this up to a
gesture perhaps and do something
respondent and animation responding to a
scroll or even hook this up to something
like motion layout which lets you
animate a custom property based on
scroll position so those are my free
kind of tenants I think that make up a
good animation that is going to survive
in this kind of reactive world but this
is really kind of an ordered list for me
essentially you can figure that as Kroft
ease hierarchy of animation needs
we're being reentrant is kind of about
correctness if you aren't reentered Ren
if your animations aren't cancelable and
working the right way so that you can be
recalled then you're going to end up in
the incorrect state so this is like
table stakes you have to get this right
in order for animations to survive in
this reactive well continuous is all
about I think having a smoother user
experience so valleys don't jump
unexpectedly which can be very jarring
and smoothness is almost like this
stretch goal for me it's like you know
the icing on the cake that rather than
just having things abruptly change
velocity and change direction then there
could be a much nicer experience to have
it to it in a smooth manner but I think
it's worth striving for because what's
the point in animating it if you're just
going to kind of half-ass it and so yeah
so that's my cake that's my conclusion
really like the I think it'll be a shame
if we in this reactive world if we were
just to give up on animations and I
think that these principles can really
help you hold them in mind in making
better animated apps thanks very much
[Music]
you